cuisiné par vous quoi vous cuisinez
proche cousine deux ou trois endroits du
tajine vous bien sûr vous vous faites du
tajine bien sûr la nommer vous il ya
même un appel j'ai un pire quoi avant la
dg deux fois ensemble deux fois un mac
do une fois une pizza frites que la dune
tout dégueulasse c'est hallucinant quoi
tu sais moi d'être un petit peu ric-rac
en ce moment parce qu'avec lui faut
toujours payer irak et dans les agences
et koidima comment faire l'étagé un pin
à la passe à la maison dit il alors à
thaksin est battu mais a tj ckoi donne
en bas âge mais ratages et puis un jean
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et alors il se doit des missions bien et
candidats devaient cuisiner pour des
enfants issus est très particulier parce
qu'il contenait des abats ou regarder
britannique la séquence bizarre tout mon
l'usc prendre dû manger une limace
vivent en maison
[Musique]
c'est spécial
[Applaudissements]